A messenger of Satan
to buffet
me less.
I should be exalted above measure.
I want to talk to you from the subject
sparring partner.
You know what a sparring partner is.
It's somebody that you box with in
preparation for a fight,
and if you are a fighter,
a sparring partner is a gift
because if you don't have a sparring
partner,
you won't be ready for the real fight.
But as foreign partner may hitch made
hurts,
made challenge.
Just because you got hit doesn't mean it
was the devil.
I want to pray.
Let me let me and then I've jumped on
it.
Hose figured out.
Thank you for this opportunity to share
the word and speak to your people today.
I thank you for what to keep Matt
Tracer,
which again,
I respect what she gave out on her.
When you get me,
I'm blessed because he said anything to
me.
Give me the ability to articulate
effectively what you have shared with me
in such a profound,
at that didactic way,
the people's lives are better because
they have shared this moment with Uli.
Speak Lord for that servant heareth in
Jesus' name.
Amen.
You may be seated.
So I went to the movies the other day
and uh,
I went to see cream.
I know I'm late,
but I went to see Craig,
you know,
with Sylvester Stallone and Michael B.
Jordan and it,
and,
and it was really,
really,
it was really,
to me,
it was a great movie,
just unbelievable movie,
but the movie's scissors around a young
man with potential
and trying to get semesters stallone's
character to train him to continue the
excellence and the legacy of his
predecessor,
his father.
In the process of training,
he is facing a daunting task of being
trained in adverse environments so that
when he gets to the stage,
nothing that is thrown at him,
we'll toss him away from the victory,
but will enable him to accomplish what
he was set out to do.
I wanted to bring it up because
I thought of it when I read what Paul
wrote because Paul is coming to the end
of a summarization of how blessed he is,
how much God has done for him,
the depth of revelation that he has and
how much God has spoken into his life.
And right on the heels of a dissertation
about whether in the body or in the
spirit.
I cannot tell us.
I knew a man who saw things that were
not lawful to be uttered and mostly
alone.
Just think that he actually is referring
to himself,
but to cast the light off of himself.
He speaks in third person.
But in reality he's saying the abundance
revelation was given to me.
It was given to me.
Look at the abundance that was given to
you.
I was ministering to somebody the other
day and it was a young man kind of
depressed over his relationship with his
father.
And when I begin to talk to him,
I said,
you talk to me about what you don't
have,
but you say nothing about what she's
doing.
Look at the infrastructure that God put
all around you to subsidize and replace
what you didn't get.
Look at all the people who love and feed
and care for you,
and maybe we will never be your father,
but we,
we represent the sum total of God's
commitment to get love to you.
Even if he had to bring it in another
way.
And when I got to tell him all of his
assets,
it balanced against his liability.
See,
life is a combination of assets and
liabilities.
And we see and we want,
and we crave the assets,
but we are not prepared for the
liabilities.
Every advancement will cost you
everything you've accomplished.
You pay the price for it,
for every accomplishment that exist in
your life.
And every victory and every revelation
and every,
uh,
economic blessing,
every kind of physical blessing,
every type of emotional blessing there.
There's always something that balances
it out,
lets you be exalted above measure.
I want you to understand that it is not
just God.
When the blessing comes,
it is also God.
When the buffet or the enemy cubs,
Paul says,
this was a gift to me,
a messenger of Satan
take with me a messenger of Satan was a
Gif to me.
My problem,
and everybody's got one.
Everybody's got something to kick.
Kick.
Everybody's got something.
You be,
everybody's got something that you
struggle with,
it let you wrestle with.
It can be insecurity and can be an
intimidation.
It could be.
Fear is,
it'd be about,
it can be low self esteem.
It could be anger,
it could be everybody has their uniquely
designed devil,
but Paul says,
this was given to me.
Why wouldn't God gives you or sin a
messenger of say the first of all,
let me stop there and talk about how I'm
glad to know that if he access me,
God had to allow it.
Okay?
The good news is he couldn't just come
at me all his old,
the very fact that he came at me,
men that he had to get permission to get
near it.
Now that's good for me because it lets
me know that God is in control,
that the devil has not been able to do
whatever he wanted to do in my life,
but I live in a controlled environment
and soda.
You are controlled environment,
a controlled environment.
God controls how hot it gets,
how cold it gets,
how much suffering you go through,
how many blessings you have.
He control.
You will not let allow your haters,
your [inaudible],
your lace,
eight years to get their hands on the
control switch of your life.
If it I accessed you,
be it good or bad,
right or wrong,
up or down,
evil or card.
If it got to you at all,
it had to have permission because you
are kept.
Oh,
you are?
Look at some ads up and kept.
I been,
I been framed it.
I,
I'm a gated community.
You can't just drive up on me.
You have to ring a bell and get
permission.
I'm David.
I got boundaries.
I got walls around me.
Don't you remember how when in the book
of job does,
the Bible said when the subject,
God came around the throat,
a Muslim came Satan and he said,
where have you been trading going to and
fro,
in and out throughout the earth.
And God said,
have you considered my servant job?
And say,
they said,
now you know you got
a hedge around.
Do you not know all the sisters?
My sisters make some noise.
All the to tell somebody I'm going kep
lover.
I'm a kept woman.
He got fences around me.
He's got various around his trophy wife.
I've reserve well taken care of.
He opens doors.
He makes ways he controls who comes in,
who goes out.
I'm a kept woman.
What my brothers at make some noise.
He's keeping me too.
He kept the gun from board off.
He kept the car from crashing.
He kept me from losing my mind.
He kept me from throwing in the towel.
He kept me from being locked up in a
jail cell.
He kept it from being at this stage and
age in my life.
I wouldn't be here right now if God
hadn't kept me,
I no,
but
whatever
access this lead has to give permission
because I know I look gay.
Community.
I'm a gated community.
You can't just walk up on this
trade.
Just walk
trouble.
Jane's doing sickness.
Can't do it.
The Preston kid blew it.
Fear of kate do it.
You can't just walk up on this property.
This is God's property from the crown of
my head to the soles of my feet.
This is God's property.
In fact,
if you 5 million,
not even
the Mama lists the Lord because I'm
Kevin.
If the enemy comes,
he has to have permission to do it and
Paul says,
it was given to me
a messenger of Satan,
thorn in my flesh,
a messenger of Satan
to buffet me.
If God says the Messenger of Satan to
buffet me,
whatever he is trying to do in my life
is bigger than what he use to buffer it.
Lead
I am saying the big tree,
then it's not in.
Getting rid of the for the colon is a
blessing to keep you from some enemy
that is worse than the corn.
The thorn is how God treats you to
balance you,
to stop you from getting too impressed
with yourself.
He's an to bless you so that if I didn't
break you anywhere,
the blessing would go so far in your
head that you would give besides
yourself,
because I hate pride above everything
else in the world.
Yet I want to bless you.
I'm going to bless you,
but to stop you from being proud of
yourself.
I'm going to give you something that
makes you drop your head.
I want to talk to you this morning about
the thing that makes you drop your head.
When people compliment you,
the thing that stops you from really
taking it all live,
something that you know about yourself,
realize about yourself,
some deficiency,
some area of brokenness in your life
that humbles you may not be spiritual
warfare.
It may in fact be a gift from God to
control your character,
to give you common control,
to stop you from being judgmental about
other people,
to get rid of your arrogant demeanor.
God will send a messenger from Satan to
buffet your flesh.
Who in the world would think that the
apostle Paul,
who was healing the sick and raising the
dead and writing most of the epistles
for the New Testament church,
the Bible sees he was getting beat up
all the time,
getting beat up,
writing,
preaching,
laying hands,
healing the sick,
raising the dead,
but secretly,
secretly,
somewhere in your life.
You can punch right now somewhere in
your life.
You're getting hit right now somewhere
in your life.
You're up under attack right now.
Have some of you think the victory is
stop the attack,
but the Lord gave me a message this
morning to tell you that the attack is
your blessing.
I'm going to mess with you that I'm a
mess with here today.
I'll go left.
Tell your neighbor the attack is my
blessing.
Yeah.
I want you to see that
it was sent
to buffet me.
The word buffet means to be big lift
fist,
something big shoe.
With this I never will forget.
It was probably the highlight.
I don't know if I should say that.
It seems like one of the highlights of
my life and ministry church was
exploding.
Muslim ministry was exploding,
going five servers.
Oh,
Sunday.
Here,
people getting saved.
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people getting saved every week.
Thousands more over the television.
People get healed.
People being delivered,
people coming out of crutches and
wheelchairs and getting touched by the
power of the Holy Ghost.
Casting demons out of witches,
screaming and hollering and yelling,
running out the door,
rebuke in the powers of the enemy.
They tried to curse me.
There's frequent chicken blood out in
front of the building.
Y'All remember what I'm talking about?
We rebuke.
The trick is I remember standing in an
old church and I told them they should
have fried them chickens.
The bands top off shit that toe.
Hallelujah.
Yeah,
the the,
the trick of blood everywhere.
I told her to shut a fried them.
I went to Babson over top of him and
check right old preaching
and that was amazing.
It was amazing.
Every time you turned on the TV set it
was when the show opened up.
Get Ready,
get ready,
get ready.
It was amazing,
but when I came home,
my mother in law died and before I could
get over it,
my mother developed Alzheimer's and so
in between the get ready,
get ready,
get ready.
I was coming home trying to get her to
swallow,
to remember love to whole food in her
mouth and then having to clean the food
out of her mouth with my hand.
I remember vividly,
vividly a great anointing service we had
over here.
I was running my own robot.
I was running my own revives people were
all backed up on the highway to come to
the providers.
I remember one service is the holy ghost
move.
People would get healed and delivered.
I left here,
I ran him to the hospital,
wet,
wet with sweat cloud low top of my
mother's bed and told God to heal her.
How could I be this powerful?
How could I call fly up down from a
habit over here and come over here and
whole somebody who's truly with it?
Wow.
Everything else.
What's going on?
Number one,
we need economic support and supporting.
The Bible says if we don't support
economically,
we are less than an infidel that we need
to provide,
but we also understand now that this
support is more than money.
So we want to talk about number two,
we want to talk about social support.
We want to talk about your social
support around you,
your family,
your,
your family needs social support.
Does it have support?
Everything in this room needs support,
support.
That gets a little boring,
but it's very important.
You came in,
you saw the carpet and you didn't see
the concrete,
but the carpet means nothing without the
concrete
support.
Have you gotten support around you for
what you're trying to do?
You're trying to build a career,
do you have support?
You've been telling God you're ready for
the next level.
Is Your family wedding?
Have you built it a love support to
support you getting ready to run for
Congress can have your kids handle it?
Have they got the right kind of friends
and support,
but he surrounded this wife had the
right support for your next move.
This is why God has given you this at
the first of the year because you're
getting ready to go to another level
and for the level that you can read it
and horn.
You can't take old support and to new
levels for the level that you're getting
rid of the coin.
You're going to need some social support
to undergird you.
It's not enough to have the vision and
have the dream if you don't have the
support and it's not just about you.
It's about everything that's connected
to you.
You want to build a great work for God,
but can the kids handle it?
Is it the right time,
the right season?
Do they have friends around them that
support your phone use or are you the
only sane voice in the life of your
family?
So what number two,
we got to have social support.
What?
I'll give you a couple of things I have
learned in life.
The higher you go,
the smaller your circle.
People who've got all kind of friends,
they know everybody and they run them
up.
All kind of the people.
I ain't going very high
because if you get too big of a circle,
you're going to have to stay low.
If you're going to be like a pyramid and
come up,
the higher you get,
the smaller your circle.
Now to take the permit and turn it
upside down and the soul gets bigger as
it goes up,
it's going to fall over.
That means you can't take everybody with
you.
You gotta be careful who you're trying
to take with you.
The higher you go,
the more discriminating you have to be
and who you got to give your time too
because we now understand that provision
is blocked just money.
It's attention,
it's time,
it's interest,
it's affection,
nothing that you have,
we'll run right without you.
So everything that you have requires
more of you and you can afford to fund
every situation you.
Oh,
it's not that they're not good people.
It's just said that you are a limited
resource and some of you are wore out
now cause you aren't too many things to
too many people.
You got to bring your circle for work.
God is getting ready to take you to,
yeah,
high five somebody said,
Lord,
that man is talking in the mood.
The third area that you need is
spiritual support.
Maybe he'd come home and support.
You need social support,
your social environment.
You need spiritual support.
Let me tell you why you need spiritual
support
because when you let me tell you
something until you let me tell you,
you would continue.
Who can I tell
every family is dysfunctional in some
way?
Maybe
they would believe that they believe it.
They didn't believe me.
Someone who,
but the frustration that we hear,
we always think everybody got something
that we didn't get.
It's not a only been raised by my mother
had been so much better if my father
would have been there.
It didn't hit on a good people with
mothers who are crazy.
There are people with fathers who are
crazy.
There are people with mothers and
fathers who are crazy.
There are people were mothers and
fathers who live in big houses that are
crazy.
There are people with mothers and
fathers who live in big houses and have
phds who are still crazy.
There are people who are fine,
who had mothers and fathers and have
phds.
They are good looking crazy.
Let me tell you something.
Every body,
light skin,
dark skin,
white folks,
but folks,
Brown folks,
everybody has secrets,
effort,
everybody,
potluck.
Everybody has issues.
Now when my comic queasy Mary go kind of
crazy,
I live,
we have five kids with five new flavor
of a crazy.
The whole house looks like baskin and
Robbins.
Have you ever notice how old are your
kids get?
The harder it is for them to be in the
house,
very easy.
When they're small,
they don't have no pagan put on the blue
dress,
put on the blue pants wearing a red
shirt.
Then one day they say,
I don't write that check.
The more premium native,
they give them more difficult to get it
and the more that the functions begin to
show and the most secrets the family has
because secrets are equal opportunity
and experiences that we all can share.
The young people today say they all had
little secrets.
They say they keep it real.
They are hilarious,
hilarious.
Then they put real on facebook and
commit a new crime because people are
talking about it.
There are some things,
if you keep it real,
you will lose it
and the reality is you get on my nerves
because just standing there staring at
me like you don't like if you said
everything you talk to people,
it would be the third World War.
Keeping it real is destructive.
You don't want to keep it real.
You want to keep her the woman.
Yeah,
I live on the Cape up woman.
Sometimes you got to such a mouth,
sometimes you've got a whole your pitch.
Sometimes you've got to be still and let
the Lord fight for battle.
Sometimes you got to say,
I take sis,
this is a job.
Fuck God.
I believe your husband,
but I can't be your daddy.
Your grandpa had the childhood.
I couldn't text you when,
how crazy itself,
but I'm talking to y'all and I'm lifting
you up to God and if God Paul Fritz and
it can't be done,
you're the spiritual support though.
You hear them say,
I'm calling for backup.
I love somebody I can't fix.
I love somebody.
I came straight out.
I can heal my or this is driving me
crazy and loud.
They're crazy and this is on top of that
drives it.
Now the kid's crazy.
It's mixed it with the crazy
have holes
probably is at a time that I am the most
tired.
I have no place to lay my head
cause there's this just I treat lid on
my son because I can't let him otherwise
because there's issues.
I can't live at home.
My husband cause there's this was,
and you wonder why you're falling apart
and why you can't sleep and why your
food doesn't digest well and you're
wondering why you had mood swings.
The reason you're having problems in
spite of all of your was is that you
have a place to work.
You have a battle to fight,
you have a job to kill,
you have a mission,
but you have no place
too late.
Okay?
Oh,
okay.
The reason you are physically sick,
right?
The reason who are hypertensive,
diabetics stressed out eating disorders,
the reason you have migraine headaches,
the reasons that you're getting
cancerous tumors is years and years and
years of being a tough guy,
crawled woman.
Reality is you had no place to lay your
head.
You can't even wash up in the service
because you felt worried about your
image that when it's time to wash up,
you're so busy trying to look masculine.
That to miss a one place.
He's got
to take the weight up off of your phone.
Hey,
I've got to stop there,
but it's been a real joy to share the
word of the Lord with you.
I believe the best is yet to come in.
I pray that the word you heard today
will produce fruit in your life
tomorrow.
In Jesus' name.
Be Blessed.
I want to thank our partners for helping
us make a difference in the lives of
hurting people.
No partnership has provided food,
clothing,
clean water,
medicine,
distribution.
It's so much more at home and abroad.
In fact,
to the mega care,
we are establishing medical camps and
health clinics to increase the rate of
survival while giving hope and healing
to a hurting community.
If you are not a partner,
I encourage you to become one today.
God wants to give you the grace to be
grounded in every aspect of your life.
You are a limited resource.
Oh,
blow out loud.
God.
It's getting rid of
for your gift to the Ministry of any
size you will receive grounded in faith
on cd from Bishop Jakes,
mind renewing series,
grace to be grounded.
It's basically a sub because it knocks
it down to your knees
and when your gift is $110 or more,
you'll receive grace to be grounded in
its entirety on 70 days,
your very own walk through the grace to
be grounded series with Bishop Jakes,
28 day devotional and unique grace to be
grounded art desk display.
Wow.
Don't be stuck in in fertile territory.
Get the grace to be grounded.
Have you seen him as responsibility?
You have turned salvation,
the work I'm coming to the Lord.
You are so performance oriented.
You think you have to perform for God
who can see your thoughts so far off?
There's nothing about you.
The Bible says that is not method before
him with whom we have to do and the one
chance you have to keep it real.
You been keeping it moving
with the one person that's safe to keep
it real with and when they can find
nothing else wrong with it.
Then they attack his methodology.
They kept asking this guy over and over
and over again to tell the story.
He said,
it's just like I just told you.
Then they took him to the first day.
Tell him again.
Yeah,
I'm telling it again.
It's interrogation.
They weren't,
they weren't even interested in whether
he could see or not.
They were using him to attack Jesus.
Some of you are up in the battle right
now and the battle is even about you.
They are using you to attack somebody
else around you.
You might be going through a battle
that's not even yours,
okay?
Because it's like you're getting the say
the right thing.
They could use his mouth
to kill his master
and when the enemy is out to assassinate
someone who was a gifted or noise or
promising,
he will always try to use somebody's
mouth.
Are y'all going to talk to me?
I'm not.
They don't care whether he's blind or
whether he could see they don't care
whether he got a job but doesn't have a
job.
They don't care whether he has a future.
I doesn't have a future.
They have to keep asking them the same
thing,
a different way.
Trying to get him to say something that
they can use to attack Jesus.
They don't care that he's blind or that
he can see that he's not here.
They are trying to get him to say
something and then the Bible mentions
that Jesus did it on the Sabbath Day.
Yeah,
and from the fact
then he healed him on the Sabbath Day.
They concluded he is a sinner,
a center.
It's not like Jesus was washing clothes
or mended fences.
Oh,
working on the Sabbath Day.
Jesus had a conversation and he spit.
That's all he did on the Sabbath Day and
from that
they said he is
a sinner.
He is a sinner.
Once people put a name on the how they
hate you,
once they give that hate our name and
the name is hateable,
they want to find a category to put you
in so that they can hate you better.
When I came here,
the pastor of this church,
the Lord told me to call it the Potter's
house in the early days of the church.
You know what I'm about to say?
In the early days,
the church,
new members are coming to me and they
say they want to know what kind of
church it is,
is a potter's House Baptist Potter's
house.
Hey,
ame Potter's house,
Church of God in Christ Potter's House
happened style church.
What kind of church is it?
So I went to God and I prayed about it.
I said,
the people want a name for the Potter's
house they want.
They want to know what kind of church it
is.
And the Lord spoke something to me.
I will never forget.
He said,
son,
don't give him no name because it's a
cage fight.
You know,
fight the name you gave her
once they got amazing that they could
say
that Jesus wasn't God,
they couldn't hate Jesus.
But when they said Jesus is a sinner,
no people who wouldn't have hated him,
no hates him off the label that they put
on him.
Let me tell you something,
and all of a sudden Jesus is up under
this cloud of suspicion that the
pharisees have created around something
that he set out to do.
That was good.
Now I'm really going to dig down and
some of Y'all with me.
Have you ever been doing something good
with good intentions,
right?
Really prime.
It helps somebody and got kicked in the
face for doing something good.
It's not like you've never done anything
bad.
You go things bad before and got away
with it and then did something good and
all of a sudden all hell breaks loose.
As you were saying,
how in the world could you attack me?
Okay,
you attack me after I paid your rent.
Talk for you to get a job opened up a
door.
You Go,
I'm off.
I don't mind being a time
when they found out it was the sabbath.
They said he is a sinner.
When they called him a sinner,
the blind man said,
I don't know.
He's,
I don't know whether he's the center
now.
I don't know anything about his
doctrine.
theology.
I don't know anything about that.
I don't know what you're all talking
about it.
I've never read the book of revelations.
I don't know what his stance is.
I don't know whether he democrat or
Republican.
I don't know whether he's got two wives
or dog or billy goat.
Oh No.
Can I get a witness up in here?
Can I get a witness?
Oh No.
Okay.
Here's our one.
I met him.
I was blind and
not the rest of it.
Y'All can fight all day long,
but all I know is that it works for me.
Touch your neighbor.
Tell them it works for me.
You are in a season in your life that
you don't have to prove anything to
anybody.
Oh,
you got to do is tell him.
is that it works for me.
I don't know about your God.
I'm not gonna argue with you about your
religion.
I don't tend to wash up Buddha.
I don't serve the moon and the stars
huddled,
carefree,
prayed to pluto
is that it works for me.
This man Jesus,
this man,
Jesus set me free.
This man,
Jesus,
Rog said my wife
stopped me from killing myself.
This man,
Jesus picked me up off the ground.
Jesus gave me a second chair.
I want somebody give yes.
How far somebody told him it works for
me,
my faith,
my faith.
Cause whenever I start praising the name
of Jesus,
then the tremble.
Because if I can't do that by the
holiday,
broken bow wellbeing,
I want somebody to throw your head back
in the Holler.
Sure
does he live in that night?
Somebody out of place
that turns water into wine.
What are the goodness of Jesus and it
all that is done for me.
Wow.
Radical.
Open your mouth
so people don't like y'all Bible
Church.
When you think about what God has done
in your life,
mules to the way we wash them,
they don't think it takes all of that.
They think that you should come the
church and the pastor says speech and
you should sit there and be quiet.
But the problem with that is as long as
I speak and you don't say anything,
it's a sign.
You're not of age.
They came to the boy's parents,
parents to speak for him,
but the parents said he's away.
He can speak for himself.
You don't need this.
Some shakes trump praise
y'all,
Lord.
If he he'll do,
he doesn't limit you.
Bless you.
Hallelujah.
For the lamb
shank somebody by the hand and tell him
something that
know
he did.
You
hear that?
A wax,
you're in Hawaii
works for
me.
It works for me.
You can laugh at me.
You can make fun of me.
You can say it doesn't take all of that,
but you want the one that was blind.
You want the one that was down.
You weren't the one that was suicidal.
You weren't the one that was that job.